muy buenos días talan pues donald trump
prometió que iba a trasladar su
residencia de nueva york- aquí a florida
y así ha sido hay un gran despliegue de
seguridad en los alrededores de esta
residencia de mar a lago está previsto
que en unas cuatro horas aterricé el air
force one que habrá realizado ya el
último viaje del aún mandatario donald
trump ejerciendo su función de
presidente después se trasladará del
aeropuerto de palm y hasta esta
residencia que están aquí a mis espaldas
donald trump como ya comentaba shaalan
ultimado en estas últimas horas ha
firmado esas 143 indultos y
conmutaciones 73 indultos y 70 con
mutaciones y también esa orden ejecutiva
para paralizar a las deportaciones de
venezolanos o por 18 meses un guiño a
ese apoyo que ha recibido en sobre todo
en esta campaña electoral de la
comunidad venezolana que al menos le dio
el triunfo en flor
pero no consiguió revalidar su poder en
la casa blanca